[Música]
muchas gracias a todos por venir soy
lucía gorjón y soy investigador
económica seguramente muchos de vosotros
no tengáis del todo claro a qué nos
dedicamos los investigadores económicos
voy a intentar que os vayáis a casa
entendiendo un poquito mejor mi
profesión
yo en concreto evalúo políticas públicas
y eso en qué consiste
bueno pues miro si una política
económica y social ha tenido el impacto
deseado si ha tenido un impacto
indeseado o inesperado si sirve para lo
que pretendíamos cómo se puede mejorar
etcétera y en concreto he terminado mi
doctorado hace medio año y gran parte de
mi tesis se centra en evaluar la renta
de garantía de ingresos la rg en el país
vasco y de eso va esta presentación os
voy a contar un poco los resultados
principales que ha encontrado
como todos sabéis estamos saliendo de
una crisis gigantesca la conocida como
gran recesión y esta crisis ha dejado a
mucha gente en situación de pobreza y de
exclusión social por eso precisamente se
habla tanto últimamente de los sistemas
de renta mínima como una posible
solución la hereje es precisamente un
sistema de renta mínima
antes de contaros qué impacto tienen os
voy a contar en qué consiste la reja y
es un dinero que se le da a los hogares
que cumplen unos requisitos el primer
requisito y más importante es que no
tengan ingresos o tengan pocos ingresos
otro segundo requisito es que estas
familias estas personas
busquen activamente un trabajo tienen
que estar acudiendo a los servicios de
empleo a recibir formación tienen que
aceptar ofertas de trabajo adecuadas etc
para que sepáis un poco de qué estamos
hablando vamos a dar algunas cifras la
primera es que un 6% de los individuos
que viven en el país vasco la reciben
uno de cada cuatro parados es perceptor
de esta renta mínima y cuánto cuesta
cuesta algo menos del 5% del gasto
público
que quiere conseguir la renta mínima que
pretende la hereje y cuando el primer
objetivo y bien claro es que pretende
disminuir la pobreza y cuál es el último
objetivo a que aspiramos con la hereje a
que la gente no la necesite a que se
pueda dejar de cobrar esta renta por
haber encontrado un trabajo por haber
salido un empleo y por que la gente
tenga sus propios ingresos y no
necesiten este tipo de ayudas qué
peligro hay bueno lo que los economistas
llamamos trampa de pobreza un ejemplo
una persona un hogar de un individuo
cobra aproximadamente 600 euros al mes
tiene difícil encontrar un trabajo hay
mucho paro busca no encuentra pero bueno
él tiene 600 euros probablemente se
acabe acomodando porque mes a mes bueno
ya tiene sus seiscientos euros
esta persona cae en la trampa de la
pobreza
yo personalmente y seguro que casi todos
los que estáis aquí no nos gustaría
estar en esa situación y precisamente
esto es lo que hay que evitar que la
gente que recibe este tipo de rentas
caiga en la trampa de la pobreza
como os he dicho lo que os voy a contar
aquí es el resultado de una
investigación científica en concreto
parte de mi tesis doctoral
la primera pregunta que quiero contestar
es realmente la hereje y cumple su
objetivo de reducir la pobreza si le
estamos dando un dinero a gente que nos
pobre realmente no estamos reduciendo la
pobreza estamos despilfarrando recursos
públicos vamos a ver si esto pasa antes
de pasar a contestar a la pregunta os
voy a decir que no existe una única
objetiva universal definición de pobreza
hay varias maneras de definirla incluso
de medirla
los académicos nos gusta utilizar alguna
definición estándar la línea de extrema
pobreza se calcula de la siguiente
manera si ponemos si ordenamos a la
población del país vasco' de la más
pobre a la más rica partimos por el
medio y vemos lo que cobra el individuo
del medio el 40 por ciento de lo que
cobra el individuo del medio va a ser la
línea de extrema pobreza toda la gente
que cobra menos que ese individuo es
extremadamente pobre de acuerdo a lo que
los académicos entendemos por extrema
pobreza sin embargo el gobierno vasco
tiene otra definición de pobreza divide
a los hogares del país vasco' en tipos y
a cada tipo le asigna una cantidad esa
va a ser la definición de pobreza que
utiliza el gobierno vasco y la respuesta
es sí la hereje sí que ayuda a reducir
sustancialmente la pobreza para las
distintas definiciones de pobreza por
ejemplo tal y como decimos los
académicos la extrema pobreza si no
hubiera hereje encontraríamos un 8 por
ciento de personas pobres extremadamente
pobres en el país vasco'
sin embargo gracias a la hereje
encontramos un 5 por ciento de personas
pobres de acuerdo a la definición de la
legislación de la hereje y habría un 7
por ciento de personas pobres si no
hubiera la hereje y gracias a la hereje
esta cantidad se reduce a un 3 por
ciento de los individuos porque queda
gente pobre si hay hereje bueno pues
esta gente es gente que no cumple alguno
de los requisitos como por ejemplo
llevar un tiempo mínimo empadronado etc
porque hay una diferencia entre ese 5 y
ese 3% según que como definamos pobreza
ese 2% de diferencia es gente
principalmente en familias numerosas
porque porque cuando la elegir se asigna
a los hogares se da la misma cantidad
para todos los hogares de tres o más
personas da igual que haya tres que haya
cuatro que haya cinco por tanto la
cantidad que les llega a cada individuo
es menor
otra manera de definir la pobreza es la
brecha de pobreza es decir cuánto le
queda a la sociedad para erradicar la
pobreza
bueno pues os adelanto que para ambos
indicadores de pobreza la sociedad vasca
está mucho más cerca de erradicar la
pobreza gracias a la rc y otro último
resultado es que pese a que no erradica
la pobreza la gente pobre es mucho menos
pobre la intensidad de la pobreza que
hay mucho en el país vasco gracias a la
rci
segunda pregunta que seguro os hayáis
planteado alguna vez desmotivan las
rentas mínimas a trabajar la gente que
recibe estas ayudas deja de buscar
trabajo se acomoda en el desempleo vamos
a tratar de contestarla lo primero antes
de dar respuesta os voy a contar cómo
son los parados que reciben esta renta
les definen dos características la
primera es que es gente con unos niveles
educativos muy bajos un 60% no tienen la
eso la segunda característica que les
define es que tienen unas duraciones del
desempleo muy largas
más de la mitad llevan más de dos años
en paro y ya os anticipo que estas son
las dos variables que más perjudican a
la hora de encontrar un trabajo os voy a
dar otro dato demasiado datos
la gente de cada 100 parados en el país
vasco este mes que no reciben hereje y 9
encuentran empleo el mes que viene de
cada 100 parados en el país vasco que
reciben hereje y encuentran empleo el
mes que viene
3 es una diferencia llamativa pero la
pregunta es a qué se debe esta
diferencia pues a eso vamos bueno los
economistas tenemos nuestros
laboratorios de economía lo óptimo para
ver el impacto de la hereje o de una
renta sería clonar a la gente que la
recibe a la gente al clon no le damos la
renta y vemos que encuentra antes
trabajo el original con su hereje o el
clon sin hereje y evidentemente no
podemos hacer esto entonces qué hacemos
bueno vemos el colectivo hereje y que
tiene unas características muy concretas
como os he dicho y lo que hacemos es
buscar dentro de la gente que no recibe
la hereje y un colectivo lo más similar
posible para así poder comparar
dos colectivos de iguales
características os acordáis que os he
dicho que 3 de cada 100 parados con
hereje y encuentra en un empleo sabes
cuántos de ese grupo muy similar pero
que no recibe la herejía encuentra en un
empleo tres de cada 100 es decir no es
la hereje y la que retrasa la salida a
un empleo son las características de los
perceptores lo que les hace tener unas
tasas de salida un empleo tan bajas
cualquier otro colectivo con las mismas
características que nos recibe la hereje
y tiene las mismas tasas de salida un
empleo
la última pregunta os acordáis que os he
dicho al principio que la gente que
recibe la hereje y tiene obligación de
acudir al paro recibir sus servicios
hacer cursos de formación estar buscando
activamente un empleo
bueno pues tendremos que saber si sirve
de algo realmente esto estos servicios
de de se están ayudando al colectivo
hereje a encontrar un trabajo
bueno aquí me gustaría dar un poner un
poco de hincapié en un tema sólo el 40
por ciento de los perceptores de hereje
reciben servicios pese a que hemos dicho
que es obligatorio si es un parado que
puede llevar cuatro años en desempleo
con estas tasas de paro la crisis los
conocidos tampoco encuentran trabajo lo
más normal es que esa persona tire la
toalla precisamente para este tipo de
gente para los parados de larga duración
es donde más importante es que los
servicios de empleo estén encima que
intervengan y que les ayuden para evitar
este tipo de situaciones
dicho esto voy a pasar a contestar a la
pregunta que os he dicho
parecido a lo que hacemos antes
utilizando una metodología muy similar
tenemos un colectivo de hereje que
recibe servicios del paro y otro
colectivo hereje que no recibe los
servicios hacemos igual que antes
buscamos dentro de esos que no reciben
los servicios los más parecidos posibles
a los que sí y que encontramos
y que encontramos que cuando comparamos
dos colectivos similares los que reciben
servicios de lanbide tienen mucha más
probabilidad de encontrar un trabajo es
decir si es muy útil es importante que
los perceptores de la hereje y acudan al
paro a realizar a utilizar esos
servicios de orientación de seguimiento
y en concreto encontramos que la
formación a los perceptores de la hereje
les duplica la probabilidad de encontrar
un trabajo y hasta aquí mi presentación
espero que os haya gustado y espero que
os vayáis entendiendo un poco más a qué
nos dedicamos los investigadores
económicos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]